Now that we know what
Google collects and
what do they do with this information,
the next question to ask, again
in a privacy policy, is do they share
this information with somebody else?
And if they do, now who are they?
So if you opt-in, you agree to it, then
they can share it with the companies,
Individuals, organizations,
whoever outside of Google.
Google collects it, Google uses it, and
then they can share it with somebody
else if you choose to opt-in.
They can share information about
people who provide support to your
organization, so domain administrators
and resellers and things like that.
So information that you give to
Google can be shared with them.
They can share it with
what's called affiliates and
other trusted businesses or persons.
Of course they will say with
appropriate confidentiality and
security, but this is really
addressing the sharing part, okay?
So somebody is a trusted business or
an affiliate, they can share
the information with them.
And finally they can share it with
the government for legal reasons.
Google has been,
actually more recently, been good about
transparency of government requests for
legal reasons and
having to share what kind of information
with the government or law enforcement.
But this sort of defines how the private
information about you is collected, used
by Google, and then shared by Google.